question sans réponse en afghanistan
voici les premières images de
prisonniers d'al qaïda mais ben laden a
bel et bien disparu ou sont les milliers
d'hommes sens et l'accompagné où sont
les grottes soi-disant piégé suréquipés
le pentagone reste muet l'appel de
yasser arafat à l'arrêt des opérations
armées rejetée par le ramasser le fplp
attentisme côté israélien mais trois
palestiniens ont été tués aujourd'hui
dans les territoires l'ouverture tout à
l'heure du deuxième congrès mondial
contre l'exploitation sexuelle des
enfants au programme le renforcement des
législations nous irons en thaïlande où
la prostitution des mineurs représentent
jusqu'à 5% de l'activité économique du
pays
haro sur la douleur migraine piqûre
fonction chirurgie elle est trop souvent
considéré comme une fatalité par les
médecins dans son nouveau plan le
gouvernement prévoit notamment d'évaluer
de classer les hôpitaux sur ce critère
et puis politique les femmes dans la
campagne après bernadette chirac
première à l'applaudimètre hier au rpr
s'ils viennent jospin décide de
s'engager à sa manière celle en quête de
cette édition en forme de portrait
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
avant de développer ses titres l'hiver
avec toujours quelques jours d'avancé le
froid est resté très vif aujourd'hui ça
va continuer image de corse où une
dizaine de villages sont toujours
isolées par la neige
image du doubs qui gèle en décembre pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps
commentaires christelle bertrand en
corse disons que la situation s'améliore
le soleil est revenu et l'électricité
aussi pour la majeure partie des foyers
quelques villages sont encore sans
téléphone après un week-end passé sous
un mètre cinquante de neige c'est le
courant entre les habitants et les élus
qui me passent plus tôt nausées du son
sont bien loin sont sur ajaccio sur
bastien est ce qui fait que ce qui fait
qu'ils ne se sentent pas trop concerné
c'est la population qui est livrée à
elle-même à moulins c'est une
canalisation défectueuse qui a privé
2000 foyers de chauffage pendant deux
jours les habitants un peu agacé se sont
réchauffées comme ils ont pu
son papa très tôt mais il faisait froid
là il faisait chou question idiote
comment
mais vu que ça caillait franchement
voilà ce qui arrive à une olive qui
prend fois dans l'hérault 50 % de la
récolte a gelé les oléiculteurs ont
juste eu le temps de rentrer deux des
dix tonnes d'olives avant que la
température descend jusqu'à -10° et
demain garder les moufles jusqu'à -11° à
clermont ferrand tous les détails à la
fin de ce journal avec patrice drevet le
reste de l'europe n'est pas épargnée en
espagne de nombreuses routes sont
toujours impraticables en raison de
l'enneigement images ici de catalogne où
les familles bloquées dans les voitures
ont été recueillies dans ces centres
d'hébergement image aussi du sud de
l'italie ici en calabre on n'a pas
tellement l'habitude d'assister à ce
genre de spectacle
l'afghanistan est donc la drôle de
victoire contre ben laden et al qaïda
dans la région de tora bora les anti
talibans et les américains sont
maintenant maître des lieux
mais le chef terroriste a bel et bien
disparu les milliers d'hommes censé être
à ses côtés également les forces anti
talibans n'ont pu montrer à la presse
que quelques dizaines de prisonniers
image aussi des pillages rapporté par
nos envoyés spéciaux à tora bora
philippe rochot sylvain viaut sont venus
se partager la dépouille d'al qaïda ces
combattants afghans reviennent de la
ligne de front avec leurs prises de
guerre qui vont de l'obus de mortier à
la gamelle du fantassin mais pour eux
c'est un trésor
la querelle éclate avec le caravanier
parce que les moudjahidine n'ont pas
voulu payer la location des indes
al qaïda est bien parti on a trouvé tout
ça dans leurs cavernes mais il a fallu
six heures pour y aller
on laisse monter les pillards sur le
front mais pas les journalistes dans le
témoignage pourrait être gênant les
vainqueurs de la bataille de tora bora
se sont contentés d'exhiber leurs
prisonniers devant nos caméras triste
cortège de gueule épuisé par un mois de
combat
le pilonnage incessant de leurs
positions par la première puissance du
monde sur 31 prisonniers
nous enverrons cases sont ils bien cela
qui terrorise la planète
etienne tête à l'amérique c'est donc ça
el qaïda l'organisation de ben laden est
à genou n'est pas encore vaincu nous ne
seront pas autorisés à leur parler les
combattants afghans ont appris cette
fois à respecter la convention de genève
le journaliste de la télévision al
jazeera ne peut pourtant s'empêcher de
demander à ses hommes
s'ils sont saoudiens ou des minutes les
yéménites lui aussi mais pendant ce
temps 2002 leurs compagnons d'armes sont
en cavale dans les montagnes ils
paieront pour eux et pour ben laden dont
on a perdu la trace
nous ignorons où et blazer mais vous
savez qu'il a passé six ans ici et il
connaît particulièrement bien la région
il a préparé son évasion et avec les
talibans il a appris beaucoup de choses
mais je ne saurais pas vous dire oui
l'air et vainqueur à caen ont promis aux
américains et au monde entier de
retrouver ben laden mais l'homme n'est
sans doute déjà plus en afghanistan
oui vous l'avez constaté mais c'est le
cas depuis le début de cette campagne
d'afghanistan les prisonniers sont tous
des sans-grade ben laden comme ses
principaux lieutenants comme le mollah
omar aussi a disparu
on reparle maintenant de cette fameuse
zone tribale à cheval sur le pakistan et
qui échappe à tout contrôle explications
agnès vahramian qui revient aussi sur
les dernières images des prisonniers
d'al-qaïda autorisé cette fois à
s'exprimer ils sont 13
donc quatre blessés en piteuse état de
jeunes arabes ils viennent lui et mène
ou du koweït sur eux les moudjahidine
retrouveront pour toute arme cette
grenade combattants d'al-qaïda raconte
que les américains les ont pilonné sans
cesse et que son groupe a été touché par
une bombe
guidés par laser des combattants mais
pas d'oussama ben laden
il y a une semaine et selon des médias
aux états unis des troupes américains
auraient repéré la voix du chef
d'al-qaïda à la radio près de tora bora
mais le pentagone reconnaissait qu'il
n'était pas localisé ben laden est il
toujours en afghanistan ou bien sont-ils
replier au pakistan dans ce qu'on
appelle la zone tribale en rouge sur la
carte 400 km de long sur 100 à 150 de
large c'est un territoire de non-droit
interdit aux étrangers où vivent comme
au siècle dernier des tribus ou les
pakistanais ne contrôle que quelques
routes
il est si simple alors de se dissimuler
dans ces montagnes
cette frontière livré aux réfugiés et à
tous les trafics à dos de chameau
n'ad'ailleurs de frontière que le nom
pas de nouvelles non plus du mollah omar
le chef suprême des talibans a pourtant
négocier la reddition de ses hommes avec
les moudjahidine avant de disparaître de
kandahar où sa maison a été bombardée
tout laisse supposer qu entre afghans
les deux bords il y a eu un arrangement
après deux mois et dix jours d'offensive
les américains ne détiennent donc aucun
chef taliban aucun responsable d'al
qaïda
donald rumsfeld le secrétaire à la
défense en visite aujourd'hui en
afghanistan affirmé que ses troupes ne
partirai pas sans avoir terminé le
travail
philippe rochot vous êtes en direct avec
nous de djalal abad donc pas très loin
de tora bora première chose ces fameuses
grottes on parlait de caverne fortifiée
de 350 mètres de profondeur alors est ce
qu'on en a exagéré l'importance ou bien
est-ce que les anti talibans sont en
train de les fouiller à l'écart des
journalistes
certainement l'importance de ces
cavernes a été exagérée puisque jusque
là les témoins qui ont pu visiter ces
cavernes parle uniquement de caverne de
6 mètres sur 6 et non pas de 350 mètres
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas encore
retrouvé
fameux bunker de même d'aden dont on
parlait temps et peut-être même qu'il
n'existe pas en ce moment les américains
sont en train de fouiller ses cavernes
de regarder aussi ce qu'il trouve sur
les corps des victimes pour essayer de
remonter la filière ben laden mais nous
n'avons pas les résultats de ces
enquêtes
deuxième chose philippe le pentagone
indiquaient la nuit dernière que deux
mille hommes se seraient échappées de
tora bora avec ben laden
est-ce que c'est plausible est ce que
deux mille hommes peuvent s'échapper
ainsi alors qu'on dit que des moyens de
surveillance très sophistiqués sont en
place oui il ya beaucoup de hip hop
terre qui surveille la frontière entre
l'afghanistan et la zone tribale mais
vous savez on a beaucoup exagéré ses
chiffres au début on parlait de dix
mille combattants arabes encerclée par
les forces afghanes
ensuite on a parlé de 1500 et puis on
est descendu à 300 puis les américains
ont dit qu'il y avait 2000 combattants
qui s'étaient échappés et qu'ils étaient
à leur poursuite je pense aussi que les
américains ont beaucoup exagéré
le chiffre de ces combattants d'al qaïda
pour justifier aussi leur campagne de
bombardement sur cette région de
l'afghanistan et pour aussi expliqué que
c'était ben laden dont il voulait la
peau merci philippe rochot on a indiqué
hier qu'un homme qui prétend posséder la
nationalité française figurent parmi les
volontaires d'al qaïda aujourd'hui
prisonnier au pakistan toujours pas de
confirmation officielle mais selon les
services secrets français plusieurs
dizaines de militants islamistes
français pourrait effectivement avoir
fait ce choix
voici un document le témoignage d'un de
ces convertis au jihad
il a été recruté entre guillemets en
région parisienne et il a été jusqu'à
s'entraîner dans les camps militaires
afghans enquête thomas dandois omar
gagnent 12
la vie clandestine des camps
d'afghanistan très peu sont ceux
aujourd'hui qui acceptent d'en parler
pour karim
nous l'appellerons ainsi tout a commencé
en 1995 sur un marché de la banlieue
parisienne des frères comme il dit lui
ont tendu la main
ils ont vu que j'étais dans la galère
j'avais pas habilités j'avais pas de
quoi manger et où il était là pour
m'aider vont proposer du travail mon cri
pour dormir et où je me suis senti un
petit peu redevable envers eux et ont
plus pris demanderez un rien de grave au
début de mon juste de venir les voir de
parler de faire la prière et tout mais
rapidement c'est l'engrenage le pakistan
d'abord pour un voyage religieux puis
l'afghanistan près de kandahar
il rejoint un groupe de 150 hommes qui
s'entraînent dans un candélabre et au
milieu du désert en ce moment là on
parlait pas savait pas qu'il allait
avoir des attentats contre les états
unis ou tel ou tel pays mais c'était
surtout préparer vous préparez votre tu
dis ouais on se prépare comme n'importe
quel pays près par ces appelez notre
service national où on préparer vos
préparez-vous il y aura la guerre et or
à la gare ils disent il faut que tous
les musulmans soient prêts à faire la
guerre contre les juifs et contre les
non croyants et aux doigts tu dis ouais
c'est bon d'être prêt pour faire un gain
ils ont quelques armes et surtout il il
s'entraîne moralement e papier pas avec
les armes et aux il les prépare
moralement à mourir cette course est la
mort karim fini par y prendre goût un an
plus tard lors d'un second voyage il est
promu instructeur là c'est le déclic tu
vois que c'est toi qui qui leur apprend
à manier les armes qui leur montrent
comment faire pour eux
pour tirer une balle ils étaient
complices forcément
et qu'est ce qu'on ressent dans ces
moments là on ressent quand on est perdu
et moi personnellement je sais perdu
alors il rentre en france et tombe dans
la délinquance
après une petite peine de prison il en
profite pour disparaître et coupé les
ponts avec les frères s'il témoigne
aujourd'hui c'est pour éviter aux plus
jeunes de tomber dans le terrorisme à
kaboul image symbolique la réapparition
du drapeau américain après onze ans
d'absence il a été hissé au dessus de
l'ambassade des états unis
cérémonie qui selon le chargé d'affaires
américain marque l'engagement
diplomatique politique et économique de
washington en afghanistan nous sommes
ici pour durer at il indiqué le proche
orient est fière yasser arafat engagé
son autorité sa crédibilité en appelant
le hamas ou le jihad islamique à la fin
les opérations terroristes on attendait
donc leur réaction est bien le ramasse
aujourd'hui a rejeté cet appel
1 cela dit ces dernières heures ont
marqué une accalmie certes très relative
dans les territoires sur place charles
enderlin jean-françois mille militants
du hamas a été tué la nuit dernière à
hébron alors qu'il tentait d'échapper à
des soldats israéliens venus l'arrêter
l'organisation intégriste lui a fait des
obsèques solennelles
en tête du cortège des candidats au
suicide portant autour du corps la
ceinture d'explosifs des kamikazes
ils scandent il n'y a pas d'alternative
aux commandos du ramasse et palestine
islamique de la mer jusqu'au jourdain
autre slogan à rafa tu dis leur que tu
refuses le cessez-le-feu
non aux arrestations politiques
l'organisation intégriste rejette
l'appel lancé par arafat en faveur de
l'arrêt des opérations contre israël à
gaza le seul dirigeant du hamas qui
soigne en fuite ni des plus dans une
prison palestinienne déclare tout le
monde sait que nous sommes un mouvement
de résistance qui continuera de
combattre aussi longtemps que durera
l'occupation alors qu ariel sharon a
interdit à ses porte-paroles de réagir à
toute déclaration d'arafat
pour lui le président palestinien
n'existe plus à ramallah l'altérer s'ils
recevaient des diplomates
tenter malgré tout une médiation en
l'absence des américains les européens
sont seuls en lice pour chercher une
solution à la crise et ariel sharon
indiqué qu'il n'avait pas pris le temps
d'écouter yasser arafat
hier en bref toujours à l'étranger la
confusion en haïti la présidence aurait
déjoué une tentative de coup d'état le
palais a été attaqué deux policiers tués
mais les assaillants repoussée il
s'agirait selon le président jean
bertrand aristide d'un groupe emmené par
un ancien commissaire de police déjà
accusé de tentative de coup d'état il ya
18 mois
rappelons que depuis six ans haïti n'a
plus d'armée et pollet et possède une
police civile de 6000 hommes et puis
toujours aux caraïbes regarder ces
bateaux qui débarquent des marchandises
à cuba et bien c'est un événement il
s'agit de la première transaction
commerciale avec les états unis depuis
l'instauration de l'embargo il ya 40 ans
en l'occurrence les caleçons plein de
poulets congelés et de maïs l'embargo
reste en vigueur mais washington a
autorisé ce qu'on voit à titre
exceptionnel pour des raisons
humanitaires suite à l'ouragan michel
silence total des médias cubains sur le
sujet au japon à yokohama
ouverture du deuxième congrès mondial
contre l'exploitation sexuelle des
enfants
plus de 120 pays représentés au
programme le renforcement des
législations et des traités et
l'évaluation du fléau la prostitution
des enfants seraient en augmentation de
2 à 3 millions d'enfants touchés dans le
monde
exemple en thaïlande on estime que la
prostitution dans son ensemble
représente 10 à 14% des ressources du
pays un tiers concerneraient des
mineures enquête sur place et les nuques
frédéric faure
ils vendent des chewing gum distribuer
des sourires aux touristes étrangers
tout ça pour quelques pièces aujourd'hui
sur la plage de pattaya le commerce avec
les enfants ne va plus au delà pour les
jeux d'adultes
il faut être majeur en 1996 la loi
taillé contre la prostitution des
enfants a été renforcée un pédophile
risque jusqu'à 20 ans de prison
patrick habite ici depuis quinze ans il
a vu les comportements changent et bat
été sur la plage puis tu voyais je
voyais un européen généralement
cinquantaine soixantaine aux moches pas
c'était chaud caricature mais c'est
souvent comme ça avec trois quatre
petits gosses au tour c'était fréquent
aujourd'hui traquer les pédophiles sont
obligés de se dissimuler pour trouver
leurs victimes avec notre caméra cachée
nous arrivons au troisième étage d'un
centre commercial dans les fast-foods
les clients attablés sont souvent des
hommes seuls autour les jeux vidéo
attire les enfants observer l'attitude
de l'homme en short et t-shirt vert
depuis de longues minutes il se tient à
proximité des deux enfants ni vraiment
proche d'eux ni tout à fait étranger
c'est pourtant lui qui paye des jeux
au bout d'une vingtaine de minutes
l'homme s'achemine vers la sortie
suivi par les enfants aucun mot ne sera
échangée il n'a pas le comportement d'un
père de petits fin c'est à dire comme ça
puisque à aucun moment il leur parle à
aucun moment il est tout chaud car on
les approche est ce ainsi fait ça c'est
parce qu'il a peur peur d'être démasqué
montrer au grand jour pour les
pédophiles en thaïlande pas de
présomption d'innocence
celui qui est surpris en flagrant délit
est exhibée à la télévision mise en
accusation par ses propres victimes
humilié publiquement conformément à la
loi française nous avons dû cacher son
visage dans votre pays vous ne montrez
pas la photo de l'homme avant qu'il soit
reconnu coupable
ici on ne montre pas le visage des
enfants mais l'homme on le montre du
doigt dit regardez le bien on ne veut
pas de ça c'est un message à vous tous
nous que vous soyez dans le monde ne
venaient pas en thaïlande ne venait pas
à pattaya 6 et 7 vous chercher comme la
thaïlande la plupart des pays d'asie
renforce la lutte contre la prostitution
des enfants
l'étau se resserre autour des pédophiles
occidentaux même de retour dans leur
propre pays ils peuvent être condamnés
pour avoir abusé d'enfants n'importe où
dans le monde à propos de pédophilie
nouvelles auditions aujourd'hui à
auxerre d'emile louis dans le dossier
des disparues de l'yonne
il y a un an il avait avoué sept
meurtres avant de se rétracter devant le
palais de justice
des proches des victimes ou des
associations de soutien se sont fait
entendre
fanny au vernis marie cazaux emile louis
six mois que les familles des disparus
attendaient cette audition depuis la
découverte de deux corps en janvier
dernier les parents des jeunes filles
veulent clarifier certains points du
dossier
mais après trois heures d'entretiens
chez le juge d'instruction
emile louis nie toujours les meurtres il
affirme avoir vu deux personnes
enterrées les corps des adolescentes son
avocat regrette que cette piste ne soit
pas prise au sérieux ça piétine
et donc une après midi comme ça pour moi
ne permet pas de faire avancer le
dossier
parce que on ne cible que sur emile
louis alors que peut-être qu'il y aurait
d'autres choses à voir pour les familles
des victimes
les explications des mails ou y sont des
mensonges qui confirme sa culpabilité
elle souhaite la nomination d'un
deuxième juge d'instruction pour faire
avancer l'enquêté plus vite et étudie
toutes les hypothèses de complicité
quatre morts et 16 blessés dans un
incendie sans doute criminels la nuit
dernière à paris tout près de la place
du châtelet
c'est cet hôtel qui a brûlé un
déséquilibré âgé de 36 ans déjà
interpellés dans le passé pour des faits
similaires et toujours en garde à vue ce
soir deux des personnes décédées sont
des jeunes sicilienne sans doute des
touristes les autres n'ont pas été
identifiés
l'exaspération des habitants de la
petite commune d'ennery près de metz
1800 habitants et des actes d'incivilité
et de vandalisme qui se multiplient le
maire menace de supprimer des aides aux
parents d'enfants vandales la sous
préfecture devra se prononcer sur la
légalité de cette disposition
valérie fournier pour faire régner
l'ordre
le seul maire utilise les grands moyens
la menace celle votée à l'unanimité par
son conseil de suspendre les aides
sociales aux familles des jeunes qui
perturbe son paisible village de 1758
habitants peu habitué à l'art des tags
des cités à partir du moment où on peut
plus raisonner les jeunes et où les
parents lorsqu on les contacte on les
supplie de faire quelque chose pour que
pour que ça change
à partir du moment où les gens ils n'ont
que des droits mais aucun devoir il faut
quand même que londres est quoi il faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose
claude est vissé devant l'école du
village dégradation des buts de hand
voilà pour les installations municipales
quant aux habitants les insultes les g2
sur leurs façades et les pétarades
vélomoteur leur met les nerfs à vif la
musique surtout jusqu'à au moins 1h 2h
du matin selon temps c'est toujours
pareil et je ne doive
elle était le garde pas obligé décidé
nous on a on a décidé de partir que
maintenant le maire passe quelque chose
je pense que c'est un peu tard mais pour
mettre sa menace à exécution le maire
doit encore attendre que le préfet de
moselle valide la délibération du
conseil municipal
en bref justice roland dumas retrouve sa
robe d'avocat à 79 ans il défend d'être
à orléans un jeune homme accusé de vol
avec arme
je suis disponible je reprends mon
travail at il simplement expliqué santé
c'est l'un des principaux sujets de
préoccupation des patients mais ce n'est
pas forcément le cas pour les médecins
la douleur comment lutter contre il ya
trois ans le gouvernement avait
encouragé à la consommation
d'antalgiques et ouvert des centres
spécialisés nouvelle mesure aujourd'hui
avec notamment un système d'évaluation
des établissements ceux qui font des
efforts et ceux qui en font moins la
formation d'infirmiers spécialisés 125
au total qui circuleront entre les
services dans les hôpitaux
et puis l'ouverture prochaine d'un
centre expérimental consacré à la
migraine de l'enfant à l'hôpital
trousseau à paris l'enfant qui d'une
manière générale est au coeur de ce
nouveau plan
reportage dans une salle de réveil à
l'hôpital necker jean daniel flaysakier
martin khaliq
dans son berceau quitterie se réveille
doucement
c'est sa deuxième intervention depuis sa
naissance il ya six semaines mamans et
papas sont rassurés parce que qu'ils
trient a reçu de la morphine pour la
calmer
c'est bien vous verrez on a donné toutes
les quatre heures au pire elle était
bien calme c'était très agréable et pour
elle et pour les mains des parents chez
l'enfant comme chez l'adulte
la douleur n'est pas une fatalité et
rien ne justifie de laisser souffrir un
tout petit je pense qu'on fait bien
contrôlé sa douleur et pas toujours bien
son inconfort qu'il est difficile pour
lui parfois de n'être pas tt de ne pas
aller dans les bras d'être attaché par
contre sur le plan de la douleur n'est
nous avons les molécules capables de les
soulager
exemple la morphine délivré par 7 pompes
elle va permettre à cette jeune fille de
soulager sa douleur desquels on
ressentira le besoin permanent alors
qu'à puis avec le pussy la vie voilà
autre progrès cette crème anesthésiante
on va les laisser en place pendant une
heure avant de poser une perfusion à ce
bébé qui ne sentira pas levé le piquet
il faudrait encore plus de médicaments
destinés aux enfants mais on peut déjà
lutter efficacement contre la douleur
avec un personnel bien formé des parents
bien informées et associées aux soins
tout cela pour que les tout petits
puissent vraiment dire un jour même pas
mal
un mot de la grève des internes
nouvelles négociations ce soir avec
bernard kouchner et nouvelle
manifestation un peu mouvementée ici à
lille bagarre avec des membres de la
sécurité du centre hospitalier régional
deux internes sont toujours en garde à
vue ce soir on reste dans les questions
de santé publique car il s'agit bien de
cela la première grande synthèse sur les
risques du téléphone au volant vient
d'être publié et elle est sans équivoque
les risques d'accident peuvent être
multipliés par quatre et les fameux kit
mains libres ni change finalement pas
grand chose une campagne d'information
sera lancée demain par le ministère des
transports romuald venant dans ce
véhicule test des caméras et des
capteurs espionne des automobilistes qui
téléphonent au volant manque de
concentration jeunes dans la conduite
cette étude scientifique montre que le
risque de collision a multiplié par 4
pendant un appel
entre téléphoner et conduire le
conducteur doit choisir car son cerveau
ne peut réaliser efficacement ces deux
activités à la fois ce sont en effet les
mêmes ressources cérébrale qui sont
sollicités du coup pour les experts en
cas d'urgence l'automobiliste branché
sur portable se met en situation de
quasi accident premièrement une certaine
fixité du regard droit devant
au détriment évidemment de la
surveillance des rétroviseurs mais que
voit-il ce conducteur lorsqu'il rivière
droit devant et le deuxième le deuxième
point essentiel c'est une augmentation
très importante du temps de réaction de
50%
si pour les scientifiques le cellulaire
au volant est dangereux en france aucune
loi n'interdit au sens strict
l'utilisation du portable en voiture ce
que dénonce certaines associations
nous sommes dans une société de la
performance c'est qu'il ya une pression
très forte pour improductifs le temps de
conduite et ça ce n'est pas possible je
veux dire produire est une tâche qui ne
se partage pas attention aux offres
trompeuses
le code de la route impose de rester
maître de son véhicule en toutes
circonstances vous pouvez donc être
verbalisés même si vous utilisez un
portables en kits mains-libres prix de
l'amande 35 euros majorée à 152 euros
si vous commettez une autre infraction
au même moment politique la france est
encore très loin des campagnes à
l'américaine mais les femmes des
candidats sont de plus en plus
sollicités à quelques mois de la
présidentielle on a vu ce week end
encore que bernadette chirac très
applaudie ici au 25e anniversaire du rpr
était un élément important du dispositif
de campagne du président de la
république il ya quinze jours vous le
voyez cette et elisabeth bayrou qui
était présenté en grande pompe par le
candidat de l'udf à la tribune alors
question qu'en est-il de sylviane jospin
l épouse du premier ministre n'a jamais
souhaité mélanger les genres philosophe
écrivain elle n'a jamais exercé de
mandat
mais elle a fini par accepter il y a une
dizaine de jours de participer elle
aussi à la campagne
quel sera son rôle sa place qui est elle
vraiment c'est le dossier de cette
édition portrait signé laurent hakim et
nadine picard sylviane qui rend hommage
aux victimes new yorkaise du 11
septembre ou encore en balade sur les
plages de l'île de ré c'est avant tout
sylviane jospin pas facile donc de s'y
retrouver
lorsqu elle réapparaît sous les traits
de scie
kaczynski thiam sylviane agacinski
depuis un peu plus de sept ans qu'elle
est devenue madame jospin sylviane est
aussi resté madame agacinski philosophe
et écrivain
alors ce n'est pas laventure de matignon
depuis 97 qui pourrait bouleverser les
choses et par exemple l'empêcher d'aller
comme avant bûcher à la bibliothèque
pourquoi je ne pourrais pas si on la
connaît si peu c'est sûrement parce que
sylviane agacinscki cherche autant la
notoriété comme philosophe que la
discrétion comme épouse
loin des fastes de la république qu'elle
ne goûte qu'avec parcimonie
elle préfère de loin pour son travail
l'austérité et la solitude
j'ai besoin de beaucoup beaucoup de
solitude et de silence pour travailler
ça je crois que c'est le lot des gens
qui travaillent alors tout cas qu'ils
écrivent ce n'est pas un métier que
d'être épouse dit elle alors les pousses
de lionel jospin continue comme avant
ses rendez vous avec son éditeur au
hasard d'un couloir jean lacouture
demande des nouvelles du premier
ministre et on en apprend un peu plus
sur les prochaines vacances hivernales à
l'île de ré pourquoi ce serait un peu
pour faire de la politique pas question
de solliciter un mandat sylviane
agacinscki préfère rester une égérie
c'est en tout cas l'influencent qu'on
lui prête sur la parité l'un de ses
ouvrages politiques des sexes aurait dit
ont inspiré les législateurs j'ai senti
que ces arguments venait quand même bien
venez en renforcer si vous mais c'est
toujours important de légitimer
théoriquement philosophiquement des
choses qui qui paraissent et qui
paraissait un peu à tout le monde vous
avez vu les sondages à l'époque tout le
monde pensait que c'était scandaleux qui
est 6 % de femmes à l'assemblée
nationale en 96 et puisque sylviane
josse peuvent continuer à vivre comme
sylviane agacinski on peut facilement la
croiser pendant ses courses de noël dans
son quartier
avec sa soeur sophie comédienne et femme
de jean marc thibault le mythe de la
femme réservée en prend un sacré coup
j'ai toujours vu faire des farces à la
fourrure est gaulé se faire des
batailles de polochons au niveau de tout
petit et c'est vrai qu'elle était dans
le par un peu gauche en extérieur enfin
la maison c'est plutôt découvrir que la
réserve à gaza ce qui ouvre aux pins sur
la scène de la campagne électorale le
jeu de rôle que s'ils gagnent s'efforcer
de respecter risque d'être un peu
perturbé on me demande parfois si les
responsabilités de mon mari ne me crée
pas trop d'obligations comme on dit et
je réponds non finalement pas tellement
sylviane le meilleur atout de lionel
comme on dit à matignon a décidé de
s'investir dans la campagne du candidat
probable
quelles que soient les imprévus
téléphone politique toujours mais au
portugal où une nouvelle donne est en
train de se dessiner après le revers du
ps aux élections municipales le premier
ministre antonio du t rès a remis tout à
l'heure sa démission
il y aura donc des législatives
anticipées il faut éviter la confusion
at il expliqué l'opposition sociale
démocrate l'a emporté notamment dans les
trois plus grandes villes
lisbonne sintra et porto le portugal à
son tour livré en kit euro comme la
grèce et surtout l'allemagne et les
allemands connus pour leur attachement
deutsch mark dont on attendait les
réactions résultat comme partout
ailleurs les kits se sont arrachés sur
place david briand
ils ont attendu jusqu'à minuit dans le
froid pour célébrer l'arrivée de l'euro
la nouvelle monnaie ne se cache plus
c'est même devenu une mode
dès hier soir on s'arrachait les
premiers sachet de pièces ce matin même
impatience dans les banques berlinoise
les banques et les bureaux de poste ont
fait salle comble partout c'est le même
précieux sachet qui est une forme d'art
marque vous avez 28 soit 12 euros et 23
sont tenus sur les nouvelles pièces des
symboles nationaux qui rassure comme
l'aigle allemand ou encore la porte de
brandebourg
des pièces qui en tout cas remporte un
vrai succès en une seule journée
la moitié des kits a déjà été vendus je
voulais surtout regarder les pièces
c'est pour ça que je vais acheter
je serais très curieux des conneries
scène les allemands découvrent les euros
et se séparent sans trop de difficultés
du mark fort sur les sondages voyaient
déjà beaucoup d'intérêt mais ça a
dépassé toutes nos espérances
on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ne nous reste
plus rien
l'engouement des allemands a surpris
tout le monde les 53 millions de kits
initialement prévus ne suffiront pas à
calmer cette fringale d'euros les
banques ont donc décidé de doubler la
mise dans les prochains jours elle puise
dans leur propre stock de pièces pour
satisfaire tous leurs clients et puis
image de la machine qui va détruire les
francs elle a été joliment baptisé la
trouille aux deux et il y en aura
cinquante mille à partir du 1er janvier
les billets ainsi percé n'auront bien
sûr plus aucune valeur
incident entre greenpeace et un
baleinier japonais au large de
l'antarctique les militants tentaient de
ralentir le transfert des s'est passé
harponner le japon rappelons le
continuent de chasser la baleine mais
parle d'exploitation scientifique
frédéric vion la scène qui va se
dérouler aucune caméra n'était parvenue
à la filmer depuis plus de dix ans une
baleine vient d'être harponné par un
navire japonais une pratique totalement
illégal depuis l'interdiction de cette
chasse en 1986 une interdiction que
plusieurs pays dont le japon bafoue
pourtant chaque année plus ou moins
clandestinement lors d'une campagne de
pêche a balayé comme celui situera de 4
à 6 ans et assez d'habitude bien sûr le
plus loin possible des caméras car cette
chasse est aussi une guerre médiatique
aux hommes de greenpeace qui gêne leur
pêche et surtout qu'il a filmé les
marins réplique en images
expliquant sur ces panneaux qu'il
s'agirait là d'une pêche scientifique un
alibi qui permet surtout évidemment de
contourner l'interdiction à laquelle le
japon est supposé être lui aussi soumis
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas dans
quelques semaines le rorqual péché se
retrouvera sans doute sous forme de
steak dans les restaurants de luxe de
tokyo au prix de 3000 francs le kilo en
france petite frayeur à mérignac près de
bordeaux le service de déminage des
armées a procédé à l'explosion d'une
bombe américaine datant de la seconde
guerre mondiale
précaution maximum l'engin a été
recouvert de 440 tonnes de sable et de
bottes de paille pour contenir longue de
choc et les éclats les marchés de noël
on parle beaucoup de celui de strasbourg
voici celui de colmar il existe depuis
25 ans il est connu pour ses jouets en
bois son vin chaud à la cannelle ses
pains d'épicés et surtout ses jeux de
lumières christophe medard jean-pierre
pasteur la nuit tombée ce sont les
enfants qui donne le signal en quelques
instants la vieille ville se transforme
en décor d'opérette 900 points lumineux
piloté par ordinateur sont discrètement
disséminés dans la cité du coup le
patrimoine architectural prend notre
visage par rapport à des éclairages de
face les éclairages de détail révèle l
architecture et par exemple ici les
arches sont soulignées par cette lumière
de proches vous ne voyez même pas les
projecteurs grâce à cette mise en
lumière le marché de noël de colmar
attire de plus en plus de touristes
un million de personnes sont attendues
cette année ceux qui ont fait le
deuxième marché de noël alsacien des
visiteurs impressionnés par ces
illuminations tout est éclairée et pas
seulement les vitrines aussi les
intérieurs des maisons tout le sport de
fenêtres les toits je viens de nuages
dont je viens d'assez loin et je suis
ravi d'arriver de découvrir la ville
avec toutes ces lumières et puis cette
ambiance à colmar la magie de noël va se
poursuivre jusqu'au 6 janvier
mais c'était que la rage à un conte 12
millions de francs soit 80 % du budget
du marché ils sont consacrés on passe de
l'alsace à la touraine elle est très
appréciée pendant les fêtes la géline
surnommée la dame noire cette poule à la
chair blanche particulièrement tendre et
remise au goût du jour le label rouge a
été obtenue en novembre dernier
reportage christophe devaux lembras
alain darrigrand 9 heures précise
roselyne ouvre les portes du poulailler
géline de touraine plumage noir aux
reflets métalliques belle mais surtout
grâce à souhait car les poules sont
élevées en plein air au grain et pendant
au moins quatre mois pour une viande de
qualité supérieure
on le prend le temps de faire sa chair
nous de notre côté on ne pousse pas trop
non plus pour pouvoir les faire grandir
et bon à leur rythme en novembre dernier
la dame noire acquis ses lettres de
noblesse en obtenant le label rouge
et pourtant la race avait bien failli
péricliter dans les années 50 on lui a
préféré des volailles plus rapide à
élever plus rentables l'élevage a
complètement disparu dans les années 80
des amateurs ont récupéré des sujets où
il y avait aucun croisement
ils ont mis les eu à prouver ils ont
commencé à faire une petite sélection et
dans les années 90 des éleveurs ont
décidé de relancer la production
dans cette voie ce proverbe passion pour
son très attachante et joseph zen on a
fait un peu si la géline est devenue
l'une des spécialités des menus de
touraine une chair très blanche très
tendre avec une légère saveur de gilly
dans le registre noisette et noisettes
grillées et puis très ferme ferme bonne
tenue gauche
les ventes de géline de touraine vont
croissantes depuis sa renaissance
la dame noire s'invite de plus en plus
souvent aux grands repas de fête la fin
d'une expérience étonnante 14 cobayes
quatorze personnes sont restés allongés
pendant trois mois complets 90 jours à
des fins de test et il s'agit notamment
d'une expérience à mener pour évaluer
les effets physiologiques d'un séjour
dans l'espace de long terme
ils se sont relevés aujourd'hui à
toulouse muriel la saga olivier combe
ils sont là après trois mois passés dans
un lit incliné à six degrés allongé 24
heures sur 24 pour manger se laver
s'occuper parfois sans peine la
condition sinequanone pour reproduire au
mieux les effets de l'apesanteur
essentiellement les membres inférieurs
qui qui change les mollets les jambes
les cuisses sauf qu'on s'en rend pas
compte du tout en feront le voit monde
sent absolument pas compte parce qu'on
se sent pas faible enfin il y a dix
jours tout a basculé station debout
l'heure de vérité pour les scientifiques
c'est l'élément majeur de cette étude
c'est à dire les capacités de
récupération musculaire et osseuse
après cette expérimentation de
simulation de vol spatial
car malgré l'activité physique l'absence
de gravité provoque des atrophies
musculaires plus de 30 % de pertes chez
certains de ses hommes et réduit la
densité osseuse
c'est grâce à ce genre d'expériences
uniques en europe que l'on pourra
peut-être un jour séjourné dans l'espace
pendant de longues années la sortie
d'une compilation d'un des auteurs de
musiques de films les plus appréciés
michael nyman l'auteur de la bande
originale de la leçon de piano ou encore
de meurtre dans un jardin anglais
il mélange le classique et le baroque
avec des sonorités plus contemporaine à
londres olivenza
la leçon de piano un film de jane
campion un film
et puis une musique vendu à 2 millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde la leçon de
piano orchestrée par un professeur
tournesol qui vit au milieu de ses
partitions michael nyman est née à
londres pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et c'est à l'ombre qui la
vendent des musiques pour le septième
art
depuis 20 ans dans sa critique musical
collabore avec des metteurs en scène
volker schlöndorff neil jordan patrice
leconte et bien d'autres et surtout
peter greenaway quel bruit ça peut faire
dans cet environnement très très
silencieux car voilà c'est ainsi que je
travaille
j'écris ici je regarde le film je
regarde mes notes et puis c'est quelque
chose de précis se passe alors
g
meurtre dans un jardin anglais à thème
de force elle revisité par l'artisan
musiciens
si vous n'êtes pas un compositeur que le
traditionnel vous fait le tout avec
l'ordinateur vous écrivez vous imprimez
moi tout ça je peux pas pourtant un jour
les ordinateurs finiront par tout
emporté
le temps d'une après midi michael nyman
nous a reçus chez lui dans son jardin
anglais
le compositeur mêle avec une grande
liberté le minimalisme et le rock la
musique de film et les minutes
surnommé par ses pairs le dandy
conformiste michael nyman nous a offert
sa leçon piano
football le ballon d'or remis chaque
année par notre confrère france football
il a été attribué à l'attaquant anglais
de liverpool michael owen il récompense
la saison de ce buteur exceptionnel de
22 ans très esthétique aussi qui
récemment a marqué trois des cinq buts
de l'angleterre face à l'allemagne en
éliminatoires de la coupe du monde
c'était le 1er septembre dernier
football toujours on a beaucoup parlé ce
week-end des exploits des de ces clubs
qu'on appelle les petits poucet de la
coupe de france saint priest vainqueur
de lille ou libourne tombeur d'auxerre
tout le monde s'en souvient il ya deux
ans et qu'elle est qui avait créé la
surprise les amateurs étaient arrivés en
finale de la coupe de france et bien
deux ans plus tard qu'en est-il qu'elles
ont été les retombées
vous allez le voir le club qui est
dernier du classement 3e division est en
pleine déroute reportage juliet guichon
christophe ignace c'est un soir de
novembre à calais il y a un an et demi
les amateurs nordistes jouer la finale
de la coupe de france cette saison
qu'elle est déjà éliminé de la
compétition et souffre à la dernière
place de son championnat 0 victoire en
18 matches
qu'importe les supporters supportent est
en dernière position
on sera toujours présent le 7 mai 2000
c'était hier
les calaisiens ouvrait la marque en
finale face à nantes malgré la défaite
ils étaient les héros de france hier les
sourires les joies la coupe du bout des
doigts
aujourd'hui les galères
ladislas lozano l'entraîneur
emblématique du club est parti il a
fallu le remplacer relève assumé avec la
succession de ladislas lozano serait
difficile je les accepte et on m'a pas
forcé pour venir j'avais d'autres
possibilités j'ai choisi celle là ir
réginal becque était le capitaine de
calais les interviews l'effervescence et
les médias aujourd'hui l'anonymat malgré
les propositions les rêves de grandeur
la plupart des joueurs sont restés au
club
ces amateurs dans l'âme on préférait
l'ombre à la lumière
facile parce que c'était des moments
tellement intense et puis tous ces gens
qui nous le rappellent régulièrement
donc même si nous on veut essayer de
l'oublier on est toujours des gens qui
nous le rappelle
et c'est pas ça contre vents et marées
il avait tenu tête aux grandes équipes
professionnelles de cette belle aventure
les calaisiens n'ont gardé que des
souvenirs fin de cette édition à suivre
la météo patrice drevet pull et
doudounes toujours de rigueur donc
l'info sur france 2 00h15 le dernier
journal jean claude renaud 7h50 aux 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra faiza
kéfi ambassadrice de tunisie en france
13 heures daniel bilalian en script
comme chaque soir à partir de cette
semaine en feuilletant un livre pour
enfants c'est noël à ce soir les dix
soleil amoureux des douze lune un conte
chinois à demain